je me suis jamais senti aussi utile dans
la vie que depuis que j'ai quitté la
célébrité est une drogue
comment reprendre le cours de sa vie
lorsque subitement tout s'arrête
c'est la question que pose véronique
cloutier dans la série l'ombre et la
lumière
j'ai envie d'entendre des gens qu'ils
rencontrent et de cynisme ou verrou
interroge du personnel wade qui ont
connu la gloire exotiques comme les
infantes joue au projet clean et d'une
quête personnelle je suis très fier
parce que j'ai réalisé les entrevues de
dames mais aussi parce que sa part de ma
propre c'est moi qui voulais partir à la
rencontre de ces gens quand j'ai quitté
juste au bon moment qu'ils aient choisi
de briller autrement qu'ils espèrent
encore renoué avec la célébrité ou
qu'ils aient choisi de quitter le milieu
de leur propre chef
la série propose des réflexions
authentique et éclairante
j'ai jamais été une fille de plan b puis
le jeu commence à me des mois peut-être
falloir que je me trouve un plan mais
parce que plus personne ne veut de moi
la série a été réalisée par marie ce lot
b qui a été également animatrice à
musiqueplus durant plusieurs années 3
marisol sur connu de l'ombre et la
lumière c'était dur de quitter la caméra
pas du tout c'est la vie qui a fait
sommes dans mon cas moi ses deux
grossesses rapprochées
pas du tout je suis très bien ballons
très bas à la célébrité c'est grisant on
peuvent évaluer qu'on peut avec on peut
vivre sans la transition est plus
difficile pour certains
j'essaie de me semble que j'ai mis la
série en gros ce que ça nous dit c'est
que ça se fait c'est super positif
on n'est pas dans le sensationnalisme je
partage tout à fait ton de pio puis moi
évidemment c'est sûr que la question de
la célébrité ici un enjeu qui
m'intéresse parce que je travaille à la
télévision depuis que j'ai 17 ans danse
et des questions que je me suis posée
j'ai reçu par contre que ça peut aller
rejoindre tout le monde c'est des
questions universelles c'est des
questions plus larges qui sont soulevées
par cette très belle série du fait du
prix mais qu'est ce que t'en as passé je
pense qu'en 2020 on a besoin d'empathie
donc cette série fait oeuvre utile parce
qu'évidemment ce sont des vedettes qui
ont connu leur heure de gloire avant les
réseaux sociaux il ya peut-être des
leçons à apprendre du passé vont tisser
vraiment pour moi un coup de coeur faut
voir la deuxième couche dans cette
série-là véronique cloutier qui vraiment
se livrent ici donc vraiment leur
échapper série lumineuse qui sort de
l'ombre à découvrir ici mais bien l'ex
andré chartier il lui fait depuis mai
radio canada montréal